hello and welcome i'm anita wood
and i manage the stanford energy
innovation and emerging
technologies program also known as the
eiet
program on behalf of the stanford center
for professional development
and the stanford bits and watts
initiative which is in the stanford
pre-court institute for energy
i would like to welcome you to this
special session
on the coordinating demand side
flexibility
of the electric grid with dr rahm roger
gopal
and diane grunick rahm is an associate
professor
of civil and environmental engineering
and a senior fellow
at the stanford pre-court institute for
energy diane
is a pre-court energy scholar and is a
commissioner
emeritus with the california public
utilities commission
both rom and diane teach courses offered
through the stanford e-i-e-t program
rom teaches the eiet 237
transforming the grid course and diane
co-teaches
the eiet203203
building energy efficiency course for
this session
rahm and diane will be talking about the
technical and policy challenges
to scale grid integration and demand
flexibility
plus the market opportunities for
decarbonizing the grid
we'll begin with rom followed by diane
and conclude with a few remarks
what are distributed energy resources
dr's refer to different types of small
scale electric devices and appliances
that can generate electricity such as
rooftop solar
they can store electricity such as tesla
power wall
and whose energy consumption can be
flexibly reduced or shifted such as ev
chargers hvacs water heaters and large
industrial fans as shown here in the
figure
existing decarbonization pathways
identify renewable
generation ders and energy efficiency
as very critical resources it is
predicted
that global solar and wind energy
penetration will rapidly increase
from 2 300 terawatt hours in 2019 to 45
terawatt hours by 2050. the drs will
represent
a large and rapidly growing resource
with 3 000 terawatt hours of distributed
solar and storage by 2050
1290 terawatt hours of energy consumed
by electric vehicles by 2040
and in addition several hundreds of
terawatt hours of
flexible loads being added to the system
energy efficiency is expected to
be responsible for 40 of the emissions
reductions and we talk about
energy efficiency measures we're talking
about adoption of better appliances and
weatherization
how do dr's actually impact the grid
so dr's are located behind meters of
electricity consumers such as homes
commercial buildings and ev charging
stations as shown here in the figure
on the distribution network side of the
grid the electric grid was originally
built such that
electricity flows in one direction from
large
generators through the high voltage
transmission network to the low voltage
distribution networks where it's
distributed to consumers
voltage is stepped down through the
network using several layers of
transformers the flow of electricity
from generation to consumers is governed
by a set of complex markets that ensure
through pricing and contracts of
different
time scales that electricity supply
always matches the demand
and that the voltage and frequency stay
within safe bounds
throughout the whole network although
the grid was the largest and most
complex machine ever built the one-way
power flow and ability to schedule
generators to provide predictable
amounts of electricity
made the operation robust and reliable
but this paradigm has been changing in
two important ways
both to have significant implications to
the grid
the first is that the addition of
utility scale wind and solar which
cannot be scheduled and are intermittent
complicates the operations of the grid
this is
being offset somewhat by storage
particularly pumped hydro and more
recently battery storage
the second change is that the excess
power
generated by dr resources such as
rooftop solar and
storage can be fed back into the grid
making
the electricity flow in the grid two
ways instead of one way
and it's important for us to understand
how can this
be utilized as a resource and managed
to improve the integration of our
renewables
and to address the other issues that
appear in our grid
dr's are mostly uncoordinated today
that is they don't operate together
towards explicitly optimizing
consumer or grid objectives
there are some exceptions however one is
that within some homes and commercial
buildings with solar and storage there
is coordination to store the excess
solar power
and use it when electricity prices from
the grid are high
also demand response programs run mostly
by utility companies
aim to control hvacs and other large
electricity consuming devices to reduce
peak demand in the grid dr vendors
also have private clouds for their own
devices such as for solar
storage and ev chargers
however these clouds are mostly used to
collect data
from the devices and to send software
updates but not really to coordinate or
control the devices
but what do we mean when we talk about
dr coordination
dr's need to be coordinated at two
levels one is behind the meter where
resources at a single customer's side
are coordinated to meet local objectives
and respond to global signals
and we can coordinate them across the
meters where multiple customers are
coordinated to provide services to the
grid
and reduce overall cost while ensuring
distribution network safety and
reliability
across the meter coordinators optimize
the system
while meeting the local network
constraints
and typically they should not depend on
the knowledge of the intricacies of each
customer
if we want the solution to scale and to
preserve
privacy and security but why do we need
this dr coordination here we have a
graph that illustrates 30 days of demand
solar and wind generation data you can
see here in red is demand
solar is in yellow and wind is in blue
you can notice that the renewable
generation is intermittent
and more importantly both sources of
renewable don't necessarily perfectly
correlate with the demand
dr coordination or demand flexibility
can be utilized
so that demand more closely matches
renewable so that's one big use of it
and in the other secondary use we can
also utilize
flexible demands to handle the
unpredictable changes that might happen
in renewables so for example if you have
a cloud passing by and there is a sudden
drop in solar production
you can respond very quickly to those
changes
another place where dr coordination is
important
is to handle the high uv penetration in
a flagship project of bits and watts
called the ev50 we investigated
how does high uv penetration 50 or more
electric vehicles becoming electric how
is that impacting the grid
so we can see here in the figure that
by adding charging on top of the
existing kaiser load
assuming a 50 ev penetration here for
the bay area that's
roughly 15 million vehicles there is a
great power
peak increase of 25 this actually can
cause significant overloading on the
distribution system transformers
and also demands on the grid and the
fleet of generation in the grid
in addition to that fast charging can
cause
large low voltage spikes and large power
spikes southern power spikes
which both can represent issues for the
network voltage equipment
at the distribution level and at the
transmission level
it can require a fast ramping of
generators
so in both these cases that we saw
by coordinating dr's we can prevent all
of these issues
at stanford we have been looking at this
problem
of dr coordination in several projects
powernet is one such project that was
supported by the doe
and bits and watts and it has research
and develop a coordination platform
that leverages the cloud in partnership
with google centec drive and sonin
we investigated how do we scale this
coordination
using the cloud in order to scale it
we need to deal with four constraints
first we need to handle all the local
power grid constraints the distribution
network constraints
second we need to handle the cloud
communication network constraints
so unlike is commonly believed from the
cloud you can't really do real
time feedback control so there is some
constraints on how
frequently can you message if you want
reliability
in addition to these two constraints in
the system we need to handle
user preferences because whenever you're
doing coordination you have to respect
those preferences
and finally you need to make it very
easy to deploy and debug the system in
the field
in order to have the scalability of the
deployment
the powernet architecture itself
consists of two layers
there is a local intelligence
implemented in a local hub
this hub coordinates devices behind the
meter for that customer
we investigated how to coordinate
storage uv charging solar
and even a smart panel that was created
at stanford
this hub communicates to the cloud that
is then able to do calculations
and interact with the hubs and provide
the necessary information to protect the
power network
while achieving joint objectives such as
shaving the peak or providing services
to the power market
and so on one of the key ideas in
powernet
is that the local hub and the
cloud coordinator they just exchange
limited amounts of information the local
hub provides some
aggregate information about its planned
consumption and flexibility and the
cloud coordinator
does a day ahead calculation that then
provides
the local hubs with power bounds
that they need to satisfy in order to
protect the power network in this way we
proved
the issue having to report individual
information from every customer
about each one of their devices and
preferences to a potential coordinator
and that turned out to be really
important when we went
to implement powernet in practice we
have implemented powernet
in several places in a lab here at
stanford
and we have two major test beds one in
fremont with 35 homes
and in a farm where we manage the
cooling of the farm
we have shown that powernet can enable
dramatic savings in terms of
the bill of the customers and we are now
investigating how can we use powernet to
provide grid services
so just to end my portion of the
presentation what are the key
challenges for scaling coordination of
dr's these are some of the questions we
are hoping to
say first of all you know how do we in
the regulatory framework to better
support coordination
the one most critical policy limits how
can energy efficiency become a great
resource
and how do we ensure equity and fairness
and i'm hoping diane you can address
part of those
questions second how do we make it easy
to scale this coordination
particularly how do we facilitate
measurement and validation
of you know your responses to signals
from the grid
how do we ensure an interoperability of
devices and
privacy and security in these systems
and then finally how do we integrate
coordinated dr's in future grid
operations
how to compensate participants how to
engage distribution system operators
to ensure the distribution network
constraints are met
and that they also have an incentive to
actually engage in coordination
and what resources are actually reliable
and cost effective for grid needs
next i would like to transition to
diane's portion of the session
where she will discuss the policy
drivers and key players
needed to scale demand side flexibility
and the market opportunities
for decarbonizing the grid so i'm diane
grunick
i'm a scholar researcher here at
stanford
but i also am a former policy maker i've
been in the policy world
for over four decades now and
i was a commissioner with a state
regulatory agency
the california energy commission for six
years from 2005 to
2010 so i'm delighted to be the person
here that's talking really about the
policy side as well as some of our
organized wholesale markets
my focus is on the united states so i'm
covering three topics just quickly some
policy basics since i'm assuming
many of you are not in the policy world
second
focusing on some of our traditional
energy efficiency traditional demand
response
ee and dr and how they can be evolving
and then finally really gain to the
heart of what are the policy changes
what are the barriers the changes we
need to
take advantage of demand flexibility as
we're decarbonizing our grid
so i'm going to get into policy real
quickly
what do we mean by policy this sometimes
is confusing
there's one basic principle to keep in
mind who makes
policy it's government you have a lot of
other people involved but it really is
government and it's at the international
level
the national level the regional level
state and
local and then it consists of
legislatures
chief executives like the president and
the cabinet
and agencies and then the judicial side
as well
and what they're doing is enacting laws
regulations programs really to try to
get
something to happen now we have our
markets regulated energy markets the
isos the
iso in the united states they are run
by non-governmental entities but they
are
regulated by the government so they're a
little bit of a hybrid
and here in the united states it's a
federal agency
the federal energy regulatory commission
that regulates our wholesale markets
so who creates u.s energy policy
federal level we've got congress
primarily the u.s department of energy
is involved though we also have as i
said
ferc the federal energy regulatory
commission and then the environmental
protection
agency but president biden has announced
that for clean energy and climate
he wants an all-of-the-government
approach so for example our department
of transportation
is getting very involved in this area at
the state level as i mentioned before we
have our legislators our governors
every state in the united states has
something called the
public utilities commission puc
sometimes called the public service
commission
i was one of five members of the
california puc
and they regulate their investor-owned
utilities
and then we also have state energy
offices in every
state in the united states here in
california it's the california energy
commission
and various other state offices and
agencies are involved in california
again
our air resources board is heavily
involved in clean energy
because they oversee the climate efforts
and then you've got city councils
so private entities are super important
they don't
make policy but they sure do influence
how it gets made what is done and then
very involved on the implementation
so that's a sense of policy is really
complex in terms of
who's involved and who does what at
least in the united states and i think
this is true for
many if not most places around the world
so real quickly
there's three major policy tools that
are used everywhere
the first are carrots that's the money
it can be
direct grants but it can be indirect
expedited permitting
the second are sticks these are mandates
these are requirements a typical one
could be the renewable portfolio
standard a requirement that utilities
build a certain amount
of renewables or procure it and then
third are what we call
sermons basically getting people
businesses to change
behaviors to understand what's available
and
in my experience the best policy
programs
use all three of these in an integrated
and longer term
fashion so let's move on very quickly
now to our traditional
demand side tools that rom alluded to
and just real quickly so we're all on
the same page
the difference between energy efficiency
and demand
response energy efficiency is providing
the
same service but requiring less input
energy
or providing more service with the same
amount so you're basically
having less energy used for a given
service
at any time demand response
is different what it is be doing is
thinking about whatever is the load i'll
take it say within a building
from a device and trying to get a change
in the normal consumption
pattern and this can be done through
prices it can be done through technology
and it may result in less service and it
may not reduce the
overall consumption so it's less energy
used in a
particular time energy efficiency is
traditionally
less energy used at any time i thought
it would be good for those of you not
deep into energy efficiency just
understand what our basic
tools are this comes from the american
council for an
energy efficient economy ac triple e
our mandate on vehicle fuel economy
standards is actually the single most
important tool that we have in the
united states
it unfortunately has been slowed down
under our prior administration
but everybody's ready to go full speed
ahead
as well right now and then you see
listed here
are other major tools that we have in
the energy efficiency world
our appliance standards our building
codes energy star
utility efficiency programs federal r d
collectively these policies have reduced
u.s
energy usage in 2017 they reduced our
energy usage by about
20 percent saving 25 quads of
energy that was the amount used
equivalent
that year for california texas and
florida
so i want to reemphasize what rom said
when we are thinking about decarbonizing
the grid
energy efficiency is our friend it's our
friendliest friend
it is very effective and it has done a
great job
so far but we can do more in this area
but i really want hope everybody is
there thinking about decarbonizing the
grid
it is not immediately just let's go to
storage or let's go to something else
it is thinking fundamentally how can we
make our buildings our industries our
cars more efficient
because that then means there's less
work that the supply side that the grid
has to do and that's fundamentally what
we're trying to do with energy
efficiency
on top of it it generally saves money as
well
we can do more though with energy
efficiency
in 2014 i co-wrote a paper for the
electricity
journal it is available i wrote it with
david jacob
who is head of energy efficiency at our
largest municipal utility in the united
states
los angeles department of water and
power and it really tried to talk about
there's a future in energy efficiency
beyond what we've done
where we can use data in a way we
haven't we can understand
operational uses in building and very
importantly we raise the idea
that we can value energy efficiency if
we focus
on location and grid integration so i
encourage any of you
who want to look at this it was a really
fun paper to write as well
then on the next year in 2015 i wrote
another
paper that was on called the next level
of energy efficiency five challenges
ahead i don't have time to go into this
but one of the challenges that we talked
about specifically
was how do we value energy efficiency
so it really is focused on providing
both locational
and temporal benefits to the grid and
that's something that we're just
beginning to think about for energy
efficiency
and sorry i'm moving so quickly through
everything but we want to get into it
this is a quick overview that the ferc
staff published in december
that gives you a sense of where we are
with demand response remember i just
finished energy efficiency demand
response
and it's 2013 through 2018.
the point i want to get across is we
haven't seen
really significant jumps in the use of
demand response
over this time period and this is one of
the opportunities
as well as challenges we have ahead i
was asked to talk about ferp
so i'm not going to go through this
you'll all have the slides but basically
ferc has been working on how to bring in
ders and demand response at the
wholesale
federal level and they started in 2008
where they really wanted the iso rtos to
integrate demand response
but it's worked its way through the
courts and everything else
all the way down to a major order that
was issued in september of last year
called ferc order 2 2 2 2
and it is basically our isos and rtos
must remove barriers to participation by
the der
aggregators in wholesale markets they
must file tariffs to do so
there was concern that it had an
emphasized made clear
demand response needs to be a
participant
and a resource offered by aggregators
and so we just had a new order that came
out
last month 2 2 2 a that clarifies that
state regulators
who have a host of concerns in this area
we won't go into it
but they can't block der participation
in wholesale markers just because demand
response is included
and this we hope is really going to be a
groundbreaker of
bringing up our wholesale markets this
is an example of a policy
change so now i'm doing my whirlwind
tour of policy
on demand flexibility i think that rom
went through this so i won't repeat it
other than to say my focus as a former
policy maker includes a great deal on
the buildings themselves
this is where we can get our efficiency
but this is where we have the host
of our devices that use electricity
that can then shape and shift and
modulate their load so they can be
a fringe to the grid there's a great
paper that came out from two
state trade organizations nazio and
nehru
in october 2019 on the benefits of these
grid
interactive efficient buildings and
again
rom went through most of them we can
integrate our renewables we can really
lower costs we can reduce emissions
and they can provide grid services so
from the policy side
this is what we look at these are the
benefits how do we get the policies to
correspond
so what are the barriers and i tried to
actually
limit them and make them big picture
enough so that
people could get a sense of the
magnitude as well as the focus
the first thing is there's really a lack
of
knowledge about this whole area by
utilities regulators stakeholders
there's some deep in the knowledge but
i'd say
overall very very little knowledge and
that is combined with there's a culture
a very strong culture by both
regulators and utilities of being risk
adverse so you put that two together and
that is a blueprint for
inaction so this is a barrier we've got
to understand and address
second one is historic silos within
utilities
state agencies state versus federal
the demand side within a utility is
often on the customer service side
a totally different group that's working
on generation
or transmission or distribution and so
even
having those people get to know each
other that's the same within
state agencies within state pucs
and then in the world we're talking
about the expertise in buildings the
expertise in
transportation that isn't anywhere near
a traditional
public utilities commission who is the
state regulator in this area
state versus federal is also very very
different
i won't go into it but the bottom line
is we don't have a federal energy policy
we don't have a clean energy policy we
don't have a climate policy
so we have just a lot of fluctuation of
what may be the emphasis at the state
level
at the federal level money money money
is my third
this is going to be an expensive
transformation
trillions of dollars and we don't have
any good funding sources now that are
focused on this
the solution is not going to be we're
going to raise rates because that's not
going to have the type of transformation
we need to do
and even at the federal level with
wholesale markets is fairly
not going to be large enough the fourth
is customer rate structures as well
as wholesale tariffs if customers are on
flat rates which is true for many many
areas
they are not incentivized to change
their usage
to when perhaps the grid needs it so we
have to make
major changes in rates the next one that
i
know others are going to talk about is
we don't have any accepted valuation or
performance metrics
and for regulators as well as utilities
that's death for going into this area
because they want to be able to forecast
what are savings what are benefits
and then you have to be able to look
back and say was that achieved
and then just overall we haven't yet
developed our regulatory
and market structures to enable the type
of aggregation we need really
pricing i mentioned and trading so all
of these are the biggest barriers that i
see
now here's my last slide what can we do
so this is my view i think we need a
very strong
shared federal and state commitment to
develop
demand flexibility for the decarbonized
grid
we have a lot of folks that have goals
on decarbonizing the grid
but i have yet to see any policy making
entities say
flexible demand flexibility is a goal we
are going to achieve
second is i think we need something like
25-year
action plans at both the state and
national level
for how we are going to develop
large-scale demand flexibility
starting and including year by year
goals and implementation steps because
we're not going to get there in 25 years
at the pace we're doing now
third i would love to see a federal
marshall plan
providing the majority of the 10-year
seed funding for making this happen
the way we are going about it now will
not work we're not going to have enough
rate increases
we're not going to have enough private
investment if we're going to get the
benefits of this
i think we need a very strong federal
push
then we need to really have a major
effort on what are those business models
programs
that will provide adequate compensation
customers need to understand what money
they'll get
utilities and aggregators also need to
understand it
again this needs to be done in a very
comprehensive large-scale
thinking the next one as i mentioned is
our regulatory market structures we've
got
small pilot programs going on but that
is radically different from a grid
that is decarbonized that can use this
type of resource
and so there's all sorts of things that
need to be done on new performance
metrics i'm very excited about being
able to use
automated analytics to create our
baselines and
forecast performance a lot of work in
those areas
and then the last one is adoption of new
customer rate structures
this includes getting our smart meters
much more pervasive than they are now
and it's going to be a major shift at
every state level
to make this happen let me conclude with
an item that rom raised which is
equity i hope i've come across this is
not going to be cheap
it may end up having benefits certainly
for the climate we need to spend
this money but we have to be very
conscious
if we're going to have it for our lower
income
communities who are often in
multi-family
buildings there are a host of
traditional problems with efficiency in
those buildings
and frankly we can do it but it's going
to be expensive
and we're going to have to think very
consciously how are we bringing in
all of our communities in this area so
that's
it my sum is it's big challenges it's
big changes ahead on the policy side
but i think it is doable and i think we
can get some great results
thank you thank you ron and diane for
this very informative
and an interdisciplinary perspective
about these current topics
before we go if you would like to learn
more about transforming the grid
and the growing opportunities for energy
efficiency
you can follow the links on this page to
enroll in the courses top by diane
and rom thank you for listening to this
session
and we look forward to you coming back
next time for stanford energy innovation
and emerging technologies program
webinar
you